the box that I was born in wasn't big
enough and growing up well fed by these
odds mags six-pack ABS fat ass flat
stomach booty bumpin belly rumblin jeans
rip team quit my years were out of
baker's dozen and as I grew from both
sides I slowly surmised that people my
size with thick necks and big thighs
weren't allowed to have a good time in a
world succumbed to augmentations tummy
tucks Brazilian butts worked it earn it
trained harder better faster stronger
longer hours at the gym more fat to burn
more laps more reps more sets not even
close
I wish you had taken this seriously you
haven't earned it am I even worth it
when I woke something had changed and
instead of rage I found solace an honest
free sample of tranquility sweet and
zesty happiness that I hadn't tasted in
many meals and on that day I was
beautiful
it felt unusual to feel suitable where I
used to be reducible and now it's
indisputable that when I look in the
mirror what I see is much clearer fear
gone sheer calm today I take time to
rewind and remind myself to find the
good in body and mind and though there
are days when you may feel lesser it
gets better but it starts with
converting that pressure that made you
feel terror into something you can sever
and separate I hope you can relate and
realize that the box only equates to
what you make it to be so before you
listen to that constant chatter and
think that all your dreams are shattered
remember if you don't mind it doesn't
matter
you
you